[Musique]
yes super il ya de la neige partout et
en plus il fait pas très chaud
des conditions idéales pour se faire une
petite fondue au fromage bien sûr
[Musique]
chauffe marcel
j'adore tremper un morceau de pain dans
la fondue j'ai l'impression d'être à la
montagne le caquelon vous savez c'est
cette casserole en terre cuite ou en
fonte pourvu d'un manche et dans
laquelle on prépare et puant sert la
fondue ce nom arrive tout droit de la
partie francophone de la suisse ce qu'on
appelle la suisse romande le mot qu'à
kehl qui signifie casseroles en terre
cuite est devenu quatre longs en
traversant la frontière franco suisse
et maintenant que je vous ai mis l'eau à
la bouche avec la fonte du plongeon dans
les secrets de sa recette qui mérite
bien qu'on en fasse tout un fromage à
temps mort à l'origine de la fondue dans
déplaise aux savoyards est
officiellement suisse et oui c'est chez
les helvètes que l'on trouve la première
recette écrite de fondue dans un
manuscrit datant de 1699 intitulé pour
cuire le fromage avec du vin elle
correspond à peu près à la recette
actuelle
ce qui ne signifie pas pour autant
qu'elle ait été inventée à ce moment là
les gardiens de troupeaux des alpes et
des préalpes en nourrissait depuis bien
longtemps avant le 18e siècle le fromage
était pour les citadins un produit de
luxe mais dans les montagnes les bergers
ou les gars on va chez eux en consommer
plus régulièrement et on peut imaginer
que des morceaux de pain trempé dans des
restes de fromage fondu et plus donner
ici et là les premières fondue au
fromage le fromage est ensuite descendus
des montagnes sa consommation de se
généraliser avec elle celle de la fondue
depuis 1950 celle ci est un plat
emblématique de la suisse est aussi de
l'autre côté de la frontière en savoie
et en haute savoie
même s'il n'est pas interdit d'en manger
ailleurs même ici chez moi
alors quelle différence entre les fonds
du suisse et les fondues savoyardes le
fromage bien sûr chaque pays et au sein
de ceux-ci chaque région a sa recette à
base de fromage plus ou moins locaux
dans le canton suisse de fribourg par
exemple la fondue ebit moitié moitié
moti moitié moitié pour toi moitié pour
moi mais non pas moitié pour toi moitié
pour moi moitié vacherin fribourgeois
moitié gruyère dans le canton du valais
situé au sud de la suisse on ajoute aux
moitié moitié du raclette un fromage à
base de lait cru de vache une spécialité
de la région qui s'utilise aussi pour la
raclette pour sa voix c'est différent ce
sont principalement les mental de savoie
le comté et le beaufort qui font la
spécificité de la recette
personnellement et sûrement aussi parce
que je suis très gourmand j'ajoute de
l'apls elle et de l'abondance pour
réaliser ma fondue aux cinq fromages
d'autres ajoutent du reblochon et vous
toutes les idées sont les bienvenues
n'hésitez pas à nous les partager ce qui
compte avec ses fromages c'est bien sûr
qu'il fonde bien démonstration le
fromage c'est en simplifiant beaucoup du
lait dont les protéines se sont liées
les unes aux autres en formant des
sortes de pelote
un peu comme des pelotes de laine si
lorsque ces pelote se forme elle
emprisonne peu d'eau et de gras ou ses
fromages est trop vieux ou qu'il est
trop acide et bien c'est pelote ne se
défairont pas comme il faut sous
l'action de la chaleur
le fromage pour un ramollir ou fondre
mais il ne sera pas élastique
le choix des fromages pour une bonne
fondue et donc tout un art
il faut qu'il soit assez ira assez riche
en eau assez jeune mais pas trop passive
et avec du goût quand même
ce n'est qu'avec de telles qualités que
les pilotes de protéines se dérouleront
et serez agents seront sous l'effet de
la chaleur glisseront les unes par
rapport aux autres et formeront enfin
ces longs fils si amusant a attiré le
plus loin possible avant de les
engloutir
cain essayer de noailles de la feta ou
du parmesan
ça marche pas c'est de la faute à
l'autre ingrédient clé de la fondue
c'est le vin blanc avec modération bien
sûr
et il n'est pas là que pour le goût qui
joue aussi son petit rôle dans la chimie
de la fondue l'acide tartrique qui
contient fragilise les liaisons entre
les pelotes de protéines du fromage et
contribuer à mieux faire fondre ce
dernier pour équilibrer un peu
elle a fondu peut être accompagné d'une
salade verte un conseil qui vaut aussi
pour un autre plat à base de fromage
la raclette dont les français sont aussi
complètement fondu ce plat également
d'origine suisse a conquis le pays au
total chaque foyer concerne entre 800 g
et 1 kg de fromage à raclette parents il
faut dire qu'il y en a pour tous les
goûts nature à l'ail des ours aux herbes
ou poivre fumée etc bref 71% des
français préféreraient d'ailleurs la
raclette à la fondue et vous lequel de
ces deux plats préférés vous dis que moi
en commentaire pendant que je déguste
m'a fendu et marc athlètes
allez on se retrouve très vite pour un
nouveau sur la planche
cher épi curieuse cher épi curieux a
très vite si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleus
merci les épis curieux pour les plus
gourmands en voici d'autres et pour ne
rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]